bonjour à tous
ce sujet
actualité récemment aujourd'hui les
transports
fois un problème climatique est un
problème sanitaire le problème
climatique parce que les transports dans
le monde c'est un tiers des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre lorsque l'addition
à la fois les émanations des véhicules
mais aussi leur fabrication et la
fabrication et la construction et
l'entretien des infrastructures qui
nécessitent deuxième sujet de l'aspect
sanitaire
aujourd'hui le les couleurs des
transports c'est à peu près de 20% à 50%
des polluants de l'air des grandes
métropoles
la conséquence c'est une mortalité qui à
l'échelle du monde est à peu près
équivalente entre celle des accidents et
celle des liés aux émanations en milieu
en occident et particulièrement en
france
l'écart est encore plus grand il ya
aujourd'hui plusieurs fois plus de gens
qui meurent des émanations des
transports en france que des accidents
de la route
alors je vais illustrer mon propos avec
les illustrations avec des illustrations
qui sont tirés de l' ouvrage que que je
viens de sortir édité chez écosociété
donc à voir où la face aux ruptures des
transports donc vous allez voir je vais
aborder des deux siècles d'historique en
une dizaine de minutes avec ensuite une
analyse critique de la situation
actuelle et de la prospective alors
premier sujet donc sur ces deux siècles
on va faire des pas de 30 ans un petit
peu à peu près l'âge est un premier pas
en 1800 dans les années 30 2008 1830 ou
là vous voyez à dessein qui en fait un
dessin d'anticipation puisqu'en en 1830
apparaissent en angleterre les premières
voitures sans chevaux qui ressemble
plutôt à celles qui sont dans
l'arrière-plan qui sont des véhicules
avec qui transportait 120 passagers sur
quelques dizaines de kilomètres entre
plusieurs villes autour de londres là
vous voyez d'anticipation c'est à dire
le dessinateur se projette
années plus tard imagine que ces
voitures sans chevaux donc avec des
moteurs à vapeur à charbon se développe
à toute la mobilité même au tricycle
avec des émanations gazeuses
catastrophique
ainsi qu'un risque d'accident permanent
si vous regardez des détails bon mais en
fait au 19e siècle donc le sait on voit
un dinosaure dessin comme étant un acte
de lobby parce que cette nouvelle partie
d'économie ne plaît pas du tout aux
sociétés de diligence ni aux compagnies
de chemin de fer qui vont tout faire
pour tuer le marché elles vont ils
réussir en l'espace d'une seule décennie
en indirectement instituant des péages
important dans les villes que traverser
ces voitures sans chevaux et aussi
quelques agriculteurs les ont précédés
de quelqu'un qui devait courir avec un
drapeau rouge devant vous imaginez l'a
dit la difficulté dans ce marché va
s'effondrer en une dizaine d'années et
donc la pollution de l'air des
transports 19e peut-être que vous pensez
à lucky luke ou western avec des
locomotives qui crache une énorme fumée
noirâtre
c'est vrai que le chauffeur mécanicien
lui d'entrelacs entre la réserve de
charbon et le voyait en décembre ne
devait pas certainement vivre très vieux
mais le plus gros de la pollution de
l'air des transports au 19e c'est en
fait la fabrication du fer et de l'acier
qui sert essentiellement à la
fabrication des rails à l'échelle
mondiale certaines années plus de la
moitié de la production mondiale de fer
et d'acier destinés qu'à fabriquer des
rails
alors si ensuite on ajoute la
construction le l'acier pour construire
les ports ou les gares et aussi tous les
trains eux mêmes ainsi que les navires
dont les coques sont de plus en plus en
acier
on aboutit finalement à ce que la
pollution de l'air des transports et
surtout au 19ème indirects là vous avez
à l'image de pittsburgh en pennsylvanie
qui est dans le coeur du passé
d'anthracite en fait la capitale
américaine de finalement de là
la sidérurgie donc la pollution des
transports cancer tout autant la
fabrication de plus fer et d'acier que
l'extraction du charbon en fait qui est
nécessaire pour faire tourner ses usines
ensuite on refait un saut d'une
trentaine d'années pour se retrouver
alors vers le tout début enfin revenir
la fin du 19e siècle avec l'arrivée de
l'automobile a on a parlé des voitures
sans chevaux avec la vapeur mais
l'automobile à la faveur du moteur à
explosion
et aussi du développement des
accumulateurs parce qu'à l'époque il y
avait aussi pas mal de voitures
électriques proportionnellement est donc
là vous voyez au tout début du xxème la
sortie d'un dimanche à paris avec une
foule considérable qui admire le chassé
croisé des personnes relativement aisée
qui dispose d'une voiture ce que vous
pouvez voir dans le dessin c'est
l'omniprésence de la poussière avec
aussi les femmes qui sont obligées de se
voiler on ne voit même pas leur visage
les autres de se protéger pour par son
pour pourquoi cette situation parce que
les voitures plus plus que le cerveau
des chevaux soulève la poussière et la
grosse crainte au 19e c'est en fait
l'homme dit présence des chevaux et
leurs conséquences a paris il y avait
cent mille chevaux à la fin du 19e
siècle sans me chevaux dans paris c'est
du crottin partout des cadavres
d'animaux morts régulièrement la
prolifération des mouches et des
épidémies dans la ville de
quand il faut il donc les premières
personnes qui ont vu arriver des
automobiles se sont même si elle fumait
beaucoup de gaz polluants
ce n'est pas grave ça sera des chevaux -
et leurs craintes étaient les poussières
qui emmagasine et des bactéries
donc il cherchait à s'en protéger clin
d'oeil vous donnerai que le cycliste à
droite lui n'est absolument pas protégé
au milieu de tout ça voilà donc ensuite
on va faire un saut de 30 en plus dans
les années 20 dans les années 20 il ya
deux phénomènes notable que je voulais
souligner c'est l'introduction de
l'essence au plomb
un ingénieur dette general motors
découvre comme étant un tout petit peu
de plomb dans l'essence qui ne ce qui ne
coûte pas cher il obtient une essence
qui a un indice d'octane supérieur donc
en fait il fait fonctionner qui permet
de faire fonctionner les moteurs un
petit peu plus puissamment et il se dit
que cela va être une source de bénéfices
colossaux il aura raison ça sera des
millions des millions de dollars à la
clé pour general motors
les les médecins alertent les autorités
publiques en leur disant c'est
extrêmement dangereux
le saturnisme en tant qu'un gestion de
peinture ou de tuyaux en plomb c'est le
saturnisme c'était dans les années 10
que le dieu que les gens en avait
extrêmement peur s'était révélé au grand
public
et là nous sommes dans les années là on
cherche à introduire l'essence au plomb
donc certaines grandes villes commencent
à interdire l'essence au plomb
la commercialisation des sens au blond
mais personne n'est capable de prouver
que c'est la conséquence sanitaire
évidemment c'est une intoxication la
honte les médecins ne s'en doutent
fortement de pouvoir rien prouvé et on
est obligé de laisser là l'essence au
plomb se généraliser dans l'ensemble du
monde pendant du le fait un demi siècle
voilà ensuite on peut passer au aux
années 50 alors là vous avez dans lequel
a sorti du so2 qu'on confie mon
conflit mondial aux états unis donc là
vous rendez un petit peu avant ou en
présente aux gens de la ville idéale
par exemple dans la l'exposition
internationale de new york en 39 ans
leur exposé l'art à la ville idéale qui
est la grande métropole idéal qui est
constitué de deux villes juxtaposés ils
sont chacune des dizaines d'activités
des villes industrielles des villes de
loisirs et des villes d'habitation avec
que des transports autorisée qui
desservent tout ça et on promet aux gens
que finalement ils auront tous faire
tous leurs voitures individuelles et que
ça sera ta liberté avec en perspective
que tout le monde dispose plus tard à la
génération d'un prêt de l'hélicoptère
l'individuel qui permettra à vous de
deviner sur l'image de pouvoir vivre où
l'on veut tout en travaillant où l'on
veut et se déplacer aussi loisirs où
l'on veut sans évidemment vous doutez
aucun embouteillage tels que c'est
présenté dit aucune pollution mais en
fait on constate que du point de vue de
la pollution il y à de nombreuses
alertes rouges
alors là je vous montre un dessin alors
vous avez une image à cause d'une
photographie du smoke de londres le plus
terrible qui celui de descente 52 qui a
fait dix mille morts en quelques jours
et puis à droite je montre une image
récente de la chine est d une grande
ville chinoise où l'on se demande
finalement où est le progrès alors sur
ces deux images vous pouvez vous dire
qu'il ya d'une certaine forme de
délocalisation alors délocalisations
industrielles parce que la pollution de
l'ombre aujourd'hui heureusement n'est
pas à ce niveau là mais il ya aussi une
espèce de délocalisation
relocalisation des bottes de vie
puisqu'on est en train d'expliquer à
tous ces pays émergents asiatiques que
leur bonheur c'est bientôt d'avoir
chacun sa voiture et de pouvoir partir
en vacances en avion
donc pour s'extirper de cette affaire et
à droite le masque bien entendu ne sert
à rien sur les particules fines qui le
traversent
copieusement alors ensuite si on avance
un petit peu dans les années soixante
dix bons apparaissent les pots
catalytiques
mais surtout les transports motorisés
sont en développement exponentiel et
donc un exemple haut d'aujourd'hui
donc là vous avez une image du port de
singapour avec des dizaines de milliers
de containers et là je voulais qu'on
était à quai par exemple parler d'eux
kane ce qui à la fin du xviiie vous le
savez mieux que moi penser que le
bonheur humain passer par la
spécialisation territoriales à de la
production de denrées ou des objets et
de les diffuser dans le monde entier et
en fait quand vous regardez sa fille
d'alors adam smith
il était passé il était passé parce que
si vous ouvrez un conteneur vous avez
80% de chance de tomber sur un produit
semi fille ce qui fait que les maths les
matériaux polymères régulièrement font
plus que le tour de la terre avant
d'atterrir dans les mains du
consommateur final via un produit
manufacturé
ça c'est pour les marchandises mais on a
aussi la version pour les personnes avec
le développement du
du tourisme aérien low cost voilà là
vous avez une image du de la maquette
numérique du chantier en cours qui a
démarré du deuxième aéroport de dubaï
là sur cette image les petits traits
blancs ne sont pas des fourmis ce sont
des avions gros porteurs qui sont
capables d'être approvisionné en
personne en parallèle est donc cet
aéroport qui est en construction
sa capacité c'est quatre fois celui du
plus gros aéroport d'aujourd'hui c'est 4
fois le trafic d'atlanta 4 fois le
trafic de shanghai cet aéroport le
développement du tourisme de masse se
cache derrière cela avec notamment un
kérosène qui déjà été détaxés
là il est vendu à prix cassés aux
compagnies locales alors là la
conclusion tout ça on dirait des dans
les années 60-70 déjà des penseurs avait
comme tel et lui le jacques ellul
bernard charbonneau que je cite parce
qu'israël s'était acquitté mais aussi
ivan illich qui avait constaté qu en
fait tous ces transports autorisé
promettent par leur rapidité de
raccourcir les temps de trajet mais en
fait ceux constatés en fin de vie n'ait
commencé à constater et pensé que ça
n'allait que s'accentuer en fait c'est
trop reposés rallonge les distances
puisqu'il ne raccourcissent les temps de
trajet est finalement là le bilan de
tout cela puisque je vous ai montré
aujourd'hui c'est finalement que les
transports motorisés ils ont quand même
deux parlant des plans de masse massy
pour transporter 30 métamorphosé en fait
le site le site à des rangs banlieusards
métamorphosé de voyageurs en touriste et
l'acteur en consommateurs alors
l'analyse de tout ça finalement pourquoi
aujourd'hui on constate sur le papier
que les transports sont plus sombre que
jamais parfois ils sont extrêmement vers
nous dit on
et pourtant le résultat
on l'a vu il est catastrophique qu'est
ce qui explique tout ça alors évidemment
dans l'histoire on peut constater à la
fois l'augmentation dépasse des vitesses
dvd de tous les véhicules qui soit sur
route sur notre dans l'air on peut
constater aussi d une optimisation
réglementaire c'est à dire les grands
comptes qui vont aller chercher entre
ligne des règlements pour pouvoir mieux
les utiliser et commercialiser des
véhicules qui seront à un petit peu pour
d'oreilles voire parfois de la triche
manifeste comme vous l'avez vu pour le
teaser gates le problème touche aussi
les biocarburants avec anne et
d'anguilles mais dont l'intérêt s'est
révélé être très douteuse pour beaucoup
d'entre eux est aussi la fragilité des
systèmes de dépollution qui ne tiennent
pas forcément bien la durée de vie des
véhicules
voilà alors à passer ce constat la
prospective maintenant si vous lisez la
prospective on va dire officiel vous
allez voir que le trafic mondial des
transports n'est donné qu'à croître les
les prospectives les prospectives vous
pourrez lire c'est à peu près de
croissance perpétuelle de 3% par an pour
l'ensemble du trafic mondial
en revanche le transport aérien lui il
est sur 5 % donc 3% par an c'est un
doublement tous les 25 ans le trafic
aérien c'est un tout
tous les 15 ans et retenez que le
progrès technique tendance y est c'est à
peu près un gain de 1% par an donc le
solde de peut-être a priori qu'une
augmentation des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et des émissions de
polluants alors aujourd'hui pourtant on
vous dit alors oui mais il ya un certain
messianisme technologique d'ailleurs on
nous promet qu'avec la technologie
elle va de sauver de ce faux pas alors
il ya plusieurs sujets dans les dents
les promesses technologique je vais en
mettre 2 en relief par exemple une c'est
la voiture électrique en la voiture
électrique elle est présentée comme
étant la zéro émission avec un élan
guillemets mais il faut bien avoir
conscience que les métaux rares sur la
planète sont en a la capacité d'aller
substituer un milliard de voitures
plusieurs centaines de millions de
camions et un demi milliard d'oeufs de
deux roues motorisés on n'a pas les
métaux sur la planète dans les 30 ans à
venir pour pouvoir faire cela c'est un
premier sujet le deuxième c'est que
l'électricité supplémentaire qui va
servir à recharger toutes ces batteries
elle elle est souvent particulièrement
polluante
on va dire le porte atteint le porte
étendard de la voiture électrique ou
alors la cible ultime
vous savez c'est la voiture autonome bon
mais la voiture autonome elle est
présente et très favorablement par ce
qu'on leur dit un ordinateur ça ne boit
pas d'alcool donc à voiture au tournant
pour un peu d'accidents la deuxième
chose la voiture tonneau belle quand tu
fais mieux que le meilleur des
conducteurs en écoconduite donc elles
polluent moins
ça c'est une présentation qui est
purement dans une logique substitutive
substitutif de déplacement on a des
placements aujourd'hui avec un véhicule
normal et on dit tiens avec
dom alors que de mon point de vue ce qui
va se passer c'est que la voiture
autonome sera beaucoup plus active c'est
à dire qu'elle va conduire à rajouter
des déplacements pour plusieurs raisons
par exemple le fait qu'elle soit
parfaitement conçu pour les
embouteillages puisque vous partez dans
les embouteillages avec voiture de
demain vous pouvez faire absolument
autre chose donc mais un petit nuage de
vous deux vous font plus peur elle donne
accès à des distances beaucoup plus
longue
et enfin elle permet de faire circuler
d'une personne tout seul dans un
véhicule qui n'a pas son permis dans
pour toutes ces raisons elle va conduire
certainement à beaucoup plus d'addition
déplacement que de que de substitution
alors finalement qu'est ce qu'on peut
proposer dans tout ça la question le
sujet aujourd'hui c'est l'émancipation
en fait le sujet c'est l'émancipation
finalement des petits dinosaures que
j'appelle perfore du quotidien que sont
devenus l'ensemble des transports
motorisés dans leur hégémonie temps 2 2
et le régime honni dans notre société
alors que faudrait-il faire pour
véritablement réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet serre at il dit les
polluants bon il veut je vous cache pas
qu'il va falloir envoyer du lourd
alors le évidemment il faudra considérer
la base le canari des véhicules
les vitesses autorisées mais aussi on
peut le considérer le prix parce
qu'aujourd'hui la plupart des
infrastructures sont payés par financés
par la collectivité et l'usagé de paix
que le coût marginal en fait de l'accès
à cette mobilité
aussi le nombre avec pourquoi pas la
mise en place d'un cadastre mondial de
la mobilité ce qui était allé dans le
virage et enfin évidemment
diminuer l'offre notamment d'énergie
fossile en évitant de chercher à tout
extraire ce qu'il ya sur la planète en
termes de pétrole notamment
et aussi de gaz de charbon est en fait
un dernier point si d'ici d'orienter la
filière des agrocarburants pour éviter
que ce soient les les usages les plus
gaspilleur qui cela pour qu'ils se
l'approprient comme ça commence à être
la tendance aujourd'hui
alors finalement je voudrais terminer
d'abord par un bon un petit il
un petit clin d'oeil leur passant de
chappatte alors le danger des particules
fines sait c'est qu'elle rentre par une
oreille et sauf par l'autre
effectivement c'est un sujet comme je
disais aujourd'hui on parle toujours
beaucoup plus d'accidents de la route
que de ce problème là donc je voulais
terminer par une espèce de méditation
avec donc le petit journal de 1926 le
pigiste rallye titré en 1926 sur un
riche américain que vous voyez à
l'arrière d'un diacre qui en fait là
devant thomas paris donc les fiacres en
1926 elle n'a presque plus la plupart
des se sont devenus des taxis
automobiles un don qu'il a pris 1
d'eternit fiacre à paris en lui disant
qu'on qui conduisait moi à la place de
la liberté à biarritz
donc je vous paierai tous vos fesses il
s'est passé et donc ils habitent presque
40 jours parce qu'en plus il n'a même
pas voulu passer par les grandes villes
et donc l'article qui est adossé
c'est à ce dessin explique bien que
contrairement à ses congénères lui cet
américain lui il sait vraiment ce que
c'est la france parce qu'il a connus ces
petites villes ces campagnes ses
habitants il a même logé chez l'habitant
contrairement à ses congénères qui ne
prennent que le train et l'hôtel et qui
finalement reparte aux etats unis ils ne
connaissent quasiment rien de la france
alors je me suis demandé si ce n'est
jamais ricains n'avait pas lu octave
mirbeau octave mirbeau était un
journaliste pamphlétaire très connu
assez bien payés parce qu'il était parce
qu'il était craint au début du 20e
siècle va être allé avant octave mirbeau
avait
avec ça on va dire sa voiture un peu
luxueuse son chauffeur avait pu se
promener dans le bande à france en
belgique est roland dernière a compté
c'est son voyage dans un livre et il
précise dans ce livre qu'il a identifié
une nouvelle maladie cette pratique
l'appelle la vitesse en parle pas de la
vitesse qui est le sel qui sont le
compteur kilométrique de la voiture et
pas celle là
il évoque la vitesse qui est le mode de
vie des gens qui commença dans les nerfs
commencent à être monté sur des ressorts
quand une vie trépidante et qui ne
pensent dès qu'ils sont quelque part
qu'à l'aller ailleurs rapidement et
toujours plus loin aujourd'hui
finalement c'est pas la découverte et la
vitesse on pourrait constater
aujourd'hui qu'amd ait finalement
victime d'un délit de bougeotte et donc
en conclusion pour reprendre un petit
peu les termes de molière je voulais
vous dire que ce qu'il va falloir
réapprendre aujourd'hui c'est à bouger
pour vivre et non plus vivre pour bouger
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]